so the six Democratic primary debate
took place last night at Loyola
Marymount University in Los Angeles
California
was much more winnow down debate stage
than we've seen in debates past there
were only seven candidates up there as
compared to like ten or twelve that we
saw before and of those left we had Joe
Biden Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren
people to Judge Andrew yang Amy
Klobuchar and Tom Steyer I think you
could make a case for every one of those
candidates being up there except for Tom
Styer who's at like one or two percent
in the polls and basically just by his
way on there everyone got more speaking
time as a result of there being fewer
candidates which is great I thought that
they got to go more in depth on the
policy issues which we the voters want
to see you know the candidates didn't
just have to give their answers and
sound bites that could actually discuss
you know that the policy matters and we
got to see who knew their stuff and who
didn't know their stuff so let's talk
first about who were the biggest losers
of the debate and then later we can get
into the biggest winners so I thought
the moderators were absolute losers in
this debate I don't think there's been a
debate so far where the moderating crew
did a good job they tend to ask
questions with this very right-wing
framing and last night was no exception
certainly when they were talking about
the economy when they were talking about
Trump impeachment when they're talking
about free college education they
weren't doing any favors for themselves
on those questions but there were two
moments that I thought stuck out as
particularly bad one was when judy
Woodruff confused
Andrew yang and Tom Steyer I thought
this was a very embarrassing moment mr.
yang what more I'm sorry mr. steyr I'm
sorry but even worse was when amnon
Nawaz was calling out Bernie Sanders
when there was a question asked about
race relations and Bernie want to talk
about climate change because that was
the topic that was discussed immediately
before and the moderator made it seemed
as though that Bernie was not willing to
talk about the issue of race and of
course the crowd erupted it seemed like
it was just like a big moment for her
rather than a moment for the
presidential candidates so I was not a
big fan of that and let's take a look I
thought burning did a good job at
responding to it and sort of like
diffusing the situation there because it
could have been a bad moment for him but
I thought the moderator was totally
wrong to step in here especially when
they don't seem to be so willing to
interrupt other candidates
[Applause]
senator Sanders that question but I
wanted to get back to issue of climate
change for a moment because I do believe
this is the existential issue senator
with all respect this question is about
race can you answer the question as it
whether in fact are gonna be D people
suffering most if we do not deal with
climate change there was also a really
dumb question about how this is the
holiday season and can the candidates
give a gift to the other candidates on
the stage or ask forgiveness from the
other candidates on the stage it was
just very silly mayor Pete I also
thought he was one of the biggest losers
of last night's debate he looked very
rehearsed especially with his anis
exchange with Amy Klobuchar I don't
think he did all that well he decided to
use identity politics and brought up how
he's gay and how he's a veteran at just
like a very forced time it didn't really
sort of fit the conversation you can
argue that Pete had the better end of
the exchange with Elizabeth Warren over
campaign finance reform not because he's
right on the issue but because Warren
hasn't been the most consistent on it
but even so like I don't think Pete came
across as very likable he sort of came
across as one of these empty suit type
politicians kind of like how Marco Rubio
was in 2016 and the question is like
will Pete have one of these
malfunctioning moments like how Rubio
had one and we'll just have to wait and
see I don't think he now functioned in
last night's debate but I don't think he
came across as very presidential or very
likable at all so I think he was one of
the biggest losers and then a tear above
that for candidates who did it just a
little bit better
I guess you got Tom Steyer I mean he was
just sort of there he didn't really make
a huge impact but he didn't mess up in
any significant way Amy Klobuchar
I mean she got an incredible amount of
speaking time she came in second when it
came to speaking time with about 20
minutes which is remarkable because
she's only got like three percent in the
polls she's that like two or three
percent of the polls and she's talking
this much but she also had a very silly
moment during the debate when she asked
mayor Pete and Elizabeth Warren to stop
arguing this is the debate Amy I hate to
break it to you but you're supposed to
be arguing
debate let's check out that funny clip
come here to listen to this argument I
came here to make a case for progress
and I have never even been to a wine
cave Andrew yang got very little
speaking time once again but I thought
he did ok he had some charming moments
also some awkward moments which we've
come to expect from him in these debates
the stage is quite big after all but I
thought his best moment was when he was
talking about the value of human beings
not just as workers but as people who
have intrinsic value and you know sort
of wrapping that into the conversation
about disabled people in the workforce I
thought he was very strong on that and I
certainly hope that he sticks around for
a little while longer in these debates
I like having his voice up there then
you had Elizabeth Warren wasn't her best
night I wouldn't say she also didn't do
anything that's gonna hurt her
tremendously either she had that
exchange with Pete Budaj edge which
sticks out talking about the wine cave
fundraiser I don't know if she did
better in that exchange than he did
really but you know just bringing up
that wine cave thing I think puts a
visual in the voters heads and I think
that was a good strategy it's good thing
to bring up she kept going back and back
to that like 10,000 selfie thing which
got a little annoying at times I think
SNL will definitely cover that if they
even have an episode coming out on
Saturday if they're even in season I
don't know but that was like one of
those weird refrains that we heard from
Elizabeth Warren
I thought her best moment was when she
talked about her age and how she would
be the youngest woman elected president
take a look at this clip senator Warren
you would be the oldest president ever
inaugurated I'd like you to weigh in as
well I'd also be the youngest woman ever
inaugural
yeah when that sort of thing is done
right it just works you know like it
either works or it doesn't work and I
think in this case it did work bringing
up identity politics can often backfire
or can just like not land as well as you
think it's gonna land but I think in
this case it was a good job Joe Biden I
thought Joe Biden actually started off
the debate very very strong up until the
halfway point I actually thought he was
winning the debate and that's for two
reasons one because he's the
front-runner and as long as he just
doesn't mess up terribly he can sort of
coast to victory so there's not much
expected of him also you know he's he's
had a tough time in the earlier debates
he often times loses his train of
thought or he gets his words mixed up or
he's just kind of like lost on stage not
realizing what's going on we didn't see
much of that in last night's debate
especially in the first half of it and I
thought he was much much sharper much
more more presidential and he looked
like the Joe Biden from 10 years ago
like a really strong performance I
thought in the first half I thought this
was maybe his shining moment when Joe
Biden was asked about if he'll seek a
second term because if he's elected
president when he runs again for
reelection assuming he does he would be
aged 82 and that would definitely be the
oldest president that we've ever had I
thought he gave a strong answer here are
you willing to commit tonight to running
for a second term if you're elected next
however no I'm not willing to commit one
way or another here's the deal I'm not
even elected one term yet and let's see
where we are let's see what happens
but it's a nice thought that's not to
say that Joe Biden had a flawless night
I thought he was noticeably absent in
the second half of the debate and he
started to trail off a little bit he had
this weird stuttering impersonation
during the last question of the debate
which I thought was kind of weird take a
look at this my wife and I have a Call
list of somewhere between twenty and a
hundred people that we call at least
every week or every month to tell them
I'm here I given them my private phone
number they keep in touch with me a
little kid and says III III III I can't
I can't talk what do I do
I have scores of these young women and
men who I keep in contact with but
overall Joe Biden didn't have a bad
night I think this was maybe one of his
better debate performances he was
overshadowed though and I think he was
overshadowed by the person who won this
debate and that is Bernie Sanders now
full disclosure here I am a Bernie
Sanders supporter but I like to think
that if he had a bad night last night I
would be able to tell you that that I
could separate my political analysis
from my fandom as a Bernie supporter but
I think that he genuinely did win this
debate he was on point he was himself he
had some great viral moments and he also
got the most amount of speaking time
which counts for something
they'd spent a lot of time during last
night's to be talking about campaign
finance reform and Bernie Sanders is
strongest on that issue out of anyone
else on that stage including Elizabeth
Warren Bernie didn't get into too many
scuffles during the debate but he did
have this awesome viral moment where he
made mincemeat out of Joe Biden and Pete
booth a judge for taking money from
billionaires let's take a look at that
moment because I think that was the
highlight of the night now there's a
real competition going on up here my
good friend Joe and here's a good friend
he's received contributions from 44
billionaires
Pete on the other hand is trailing Pete
you only got 39 billionaires
contributing so Pete we look forward to
you I know you're an energetic guy and a
competitive guy to see if you could take
on Joe on that issue but what is not
what is not a laughing matter my friends
this is why three people own more wealth
than the bottom half so is this debate
going to cause some major shift in the
polls no I don't think so I think Joe
Biden did what he had to do to maintain
frontrunner status maybe because Bernie
had a good night he'll continue on his
trajectory of catching up on by in a
little bit maybe uptick a few percentage
points but nothing crazy I think that
the top two will stay where they are
mayor Pete maybe he'll go down in the
polls a little bit because he didn't
come across all that well I don't think
but overall better debate having fewer
candidates on the stage helps it be a
better debate and we're actually getting
close to the voting time now voting
starts in February there's one more
debate before the Iowa caucus and so far
five candidates have qualified that
includes Joe Biden Elizabeth Warren
Bernie Sanders Pete Budaj edge and Amy
Klobuchar somehow but I'm eager to see
where this race goes and that's gonna
wrap things up so Monday we're going to
have a new show but there's not gonna be
a bonus show on Monday Tuesday and
Wednesday were sending out repeat shows
for Christmas so no new content there
and then Thursday and Friday of next
week we're gonna have themed shows and
then we will be back on Monday the 30th
so for those of you who celebrate
Christmas Merry Christmas Happy New Year
to everyone too which is also coming up
soon although we'll see before the new
year starts and thanks everyone for
tuning in
I'll see you soon